هل اقتربت الحرب؟
ماذا لو قامت حرب بين إسرائيل وإيران؟
أسيكون ذلك أمر منطقي؟
لكن السؤال الأكثر واقعية،
هو كيف سيكون الموقف العربي
في حال نشوب حرب بين إيران وإسرائيل؟
نعود للسؤال مرة أخرى،
هل اقتربت الحرب بين إيران وإسرائيل حقا؟
، وأي صف ستختار الدول المطبعة مع إسرائيل،
وما هو موقف السعودية خصوصا
ودول الخليج  والدول المعادية لإيران؟
هل سيكونون على أرض المعركة
أو في مدرجات المشجعين؟
أصبح هذا هو السؤال  المطروح
وبقوة على الساحتين العربية والدولية،
فهل من إجابة مقنعة وواضحة تفسر ما يجري؟
المؤشرات والتصريحات والتهديدات
تُنقل ساعة بعد ساعة
وجميعها تصل لنقطة واحدة وتؤكد
بأن المواجهة اقتربت كثيرا.
فما هو ثمن هذه الحرب إن وقعت؟
...
في عام ٢٠٢١
شكلت إسرائيل تحالفا أمنيا في الخليج
لمواجهة إيران،
بينما كان الرد من إيران أنها ستمحو إسرائيل
من الخريطة وخلال نصف ساعة فقط.
تدخل إسرائيل عام 2022
وهي تواجه تحديات داخلية وأخرى خارجية،
يصعب التكهن بتطوراتها،
وهو ذات الوضع بالنسبة للإيرانيين،
فيما لو نشبت حرب بين إيران وإسرائيل..
من هو الأقوى عسكريا ولمن ستكون الغلبة؟
كانت إيران تحصل على الأسلحة الإسرائيلية سابقا،
لكن إسرائيل شنت العديد من الهجمات الجوية،
على بعض قواعد الحرس الثوري الإيراني،
وها هي إسرائيل تستغل العلاقات المتوترة لإيران
مع بعض الدول المجاورة خصوصا العربية منها،
وتريد ممارسة الضغط على طهران،
بينما جاء انسحاب الولايات المتحدة
من الاتفاق النووي مع طهران
نتيجة  للأوضاع الحالية وهكذا صارت المنطقة
حبلى بتوترات  ليس في سوريا فحسب
بل في الجوار الإيراني أيضا،
فإذا فشل الاتفاق النووي بالكامل
واستأنفت طهران تنشيط برنامجها النووي العسكري،
فإن إسرائيل سوف تحظى، بدعم دولي
لمواجهة إيران وحينها قد يصل لهيب الحرب
للأراضي الإيرانية،،
...
(بمقارنة بسيطة)
يبلغ سكان إيران 82 مليون نسمة
وإسرائيل 8.3 مليون
بينما الميزانية العسكرية الإيرانية تبلغ
6.3 مليار دولار
مقابل 20 مليار دولار لإسرائيل.
ويتكون الجيش الإيراني من 534 ألف عنصر،
وهي أكبر قوة في الشرق الأوسط،
مقابل 170 ألفا لإسرائيل
وتمتلك إيران 1650 دبابة
وعدد الدبابات الإسرائيلية 2760.
أما في التصنيف العسكري
فإيران في المرتبة الرابعة العشرة عالميا،
تقابلها إسرائيل في المرتبة العشرين، عالميا كذلك،
لكن تبقى القوة الجوية هي العنصر الحاسم
في أي مواجهة محتملة بين الجانبين
حيث تمتلك إيران 505 طائرة عسكرية
وإسرائيل 596 من بينها مقاتلات F35،
وعدد القطع البحرية الحربية لدى إيران
398 قطعة، مقابل 65 إسرائيلية.
أما فيما يخص الرؤوس النووية،
فتمتلك إسرائيل بين 100 إلى 500 رأس نووي
بقوة 50 ميغا طن،،،
في الجانب المقابل لم تمتلك إيران بعد الرؤوس النووية،
ولازالت في طور الإنشاء لإنتاجها
خلال السنوات المقبلة،
كما أن إسرائيل تمتلك القبة الحديدية
الواقية من الصواريخ،
لكن سبق وأن اخترقت حماس هذه القبة،
مدعومة من إيران،
..
في حال نشوب حرب فإنه من الصعوبة
بمكان للقوات البرية الإسرائيلية بلوغ أراضي إيران،
لذا ستكون الحرب عبارة عن ضربات جوية
وصاروخية ضد أهداف إيرانية
ومن المحتمل أن تنضم القوة البحرية الإسرائيلية
إلى الجوية.
أما بخصوص إيران، فيصعب عليها أيضا
شن هجوم بري ضد إسرائيل نظرا لبعد المسافة،
ولكنها تمتلك حلفاء بالقرب من العدو الإسرائيلي،
ويقف العرب في شبه الجزيرة بين دول متخبطة
تعيش أوضاعا لا تسمح لها بدعم هذا الطرف أو ذاك،
بينما دول الخليج تميل إلى التطبيع مع إسرائيل
وتعتبر إيران عدوا لها...
لطالما هددت إيران وإسرائيل بعضهما،
لكن لأشيء حدث من ذلك على الأرض،
مع أن خيار الحرب المباشرة  وارد جدا،
وإذا ما تواجهت الدولتان فإن التقنية
والأسلحة المتطورة والقوة الجوية
تميل بوضوح للجانب الإسرائيلي،
بينما الكثرة البشرية والمساحة الواسعة
والقوة البحرية والعمل بسرية تامة
سترجح كفة إيران،
وبين هذا وذاك تحالفات من هنا ومصالح من هناك،
وأرض المعركة فقط
هي من ستظهر من الأقوى ومن سينتصر،
فلمن ستكون الغلبة عندها؟